on this episode we talk about Amy
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 292 of the askgaryvee
show on a Friday night in early fall
I'm personally salty as [ __ ] the Jets
had just lost to the Cleveland Browns I
landed at 2:30 in the morning from
Cleveland big shout out to the Cleveland
Brown fans super classy probably helped
that every other one knew who I was and
it took so I took the first selfies ever
with mean face in my life
fans rolling up on me after the game ask
for selfies and I didn't have any smiles
in my body at that point so super salty
energy maybe off Jeff specifically says
don't bring that up and now you got that
out the way so Jeff is super smart
that's exactly right
I'm really upset actually like genuinely
I've come to realize the Jets are my
bizarro alternative universe version of
myself it's where I'm pessimist a little
AJ will cosign this because AJ never
like he likes to razz me he doesn't like
to be like yeah he doesn't like support
he likes to like call out I literally on
the way there was walk in the stadium
I'm like bro I had this weird dream that
the Jets are gonna be up 22 7 and then
Baker's gonna come in and they're gonna
win 2120 and it was 14 nothing instead
of 20 to 7 but literally literally the
only thing that I did not want to happen
in the Senate all season happened Baker
took a [ __ ] on my face very game no it
wasn't a good game bro it wasn't a good
game it was good I'm sure people were
entertained I'm glad like America got to
see young quarterbacks that they think
we're the future of the league it's very
nice for everybody except for me there
some huh well listen you guys have both
talked so you might as well introduce
yourself why don't you tell the Vayner
nation who you are we're gonna get to
the calls today because I think you guys
are young entrepreneurs artists I'm
inspired by you guys so much so that I
went into business with you I tend to
never want to do [ __ ] like this where
like I mixed my real life with the
content of my show but I felt that it
was important because I thought that you
guys could you guys represent something
to me which is there's a young hustler
social media arbitrage understanding the
culture
knowing what the [ __ ] going on like
guy and gal out there today that 98% of
them are fakers and will be weeded out
and it's very rare for me to find the
real in the [ __ ] and you got a
little bit your [ __ ] yep
you know you guys have a little
especially he's good you still you still
got like meaning by the chance meaning
meaning and I mean I'm obviously making
a joke but mean like it's such a special
interesting time in entrepreneurship
right it's such a special time it's been
put on a cool factor the fact that cool
people follow me and think it's cool
yeah that makes great you don't know you
are too young to know this all of you
[ __ ] it's crazy and it'd be literally
like got me telling you like yo you'll
never believe this in 20 years
construction workers are gonna be as
popular as [ __ ] rappers that is
literally literally what I would tell
you it would have sounded like if 29
years ago I said to you entrepreneurs
would be as cool as athletes and rappers
literally so very special time
but you guys have executed so say hello
I'm mark mark Brazil and me and Jeff own
a company called iconic I do the
business Jeff does the art I'm the
digital artist and I do half of the
business because of you actually episode
you when it started Gary yeah I was on
the island by myself doing all the
business and literally the artist and
usually you guys motional I was like a
stereotypical artist yeah he's got I did
for you what I did for d-roc
systematically broke you down from your
[ __ ] and ideology to being more
practical Jeff gives a valuable business
advice now now like and that freaks you
out a little bit I love it the more the
merrier I mean just I mean and tell your
origin story this was comic book number
one
congra like what did you guys like like
your girlfriends were dating and you met
but grudgingly where you been really
welcome in and I told you guys were
cliche good eight years ago an NYU dorm
I wake up at 8:00 a.m.
next a girl and she tells me you need
you need to meet this guy Jeff Cole who
at that time I swear to God already
referred for no reason at all I had a
comic you guys had a similar hookup
style or not at all actually um I had a
comic book t-shirt company and she
connected me with him and we for three
years I independently contracted him we
only talked over Gmail we had never even
met before and would be nice both in New
York no I was in Chicago at the time I
was in high school it's girl you just do
like um no I'm sorry I was at the
University of Arizona
okay and you knew her I wasn't meeting
this woman yet no she went to Arizona
with me and I didn't even do digital art
yet I was kind of I just majored in
illustration at Arizona and it basically
she knew you were good artist yeah you
guys hook up yeah and the wake up
conversation from the hook up is chef
Cole yeah it's it's so ironic and
literally it's it's nice do you guys
like you guys like let's talk about this
for a minute we I wish her happy
birthday every year on Facebook you got
to do way more than a birthday on
Facebook to people you once we're in
study hall with you do not wish happy
you need to sell her a ton of all you
need to send her a ton of art isn't
gonna do it you need to email her DM her
or text her and find out what she's into
in life you guys need the buyer like you
need to do something right didn't end oh
well that's fine but it's 100 years ago
I know you need to man up and realize it
ended up great yeah it's it's funny how
things work out because literally bro it
ended great we may not be together yeah
but you found your business love do you
guys consider each other business loves
I love him like a brother yes that's
right yeah you found your business love
thus it was it worked out great yeah and
we need to do wait can we make a
commitment here today now that I'm part
of the company yeah can we make a
commitment yeah what's your first name
Amy can we make a commitment to Amy have
you shot ours now can we make a
commitment to aim
that we have to recognize the way life
actually works though it may have not
ended up the way you wanted to or nicely
in a romantic sense
she created a monster a monster yeah I
do love her for that I mean but not
you're not showing it that's true
you love it once a year Jeff you need to
step up you weren't your heart or your
relationship wasn't bad you need to
wasn't your he was in it I've everything
for that you on the other hand this is
actually your fault you need to be the
one that needs to step up and do the
right thing by Amy well-named you make
can you make me a piece of art that says
do the right thing by Amy right there
I'll make it right there I've just I
didn't even realize I had that space up
there right there let's measure it do
the right thing by Amy I want it yeah
that on camera so it's done it's going
down all right we was that can we
alright so origin story you wake up hook
up in college style you got to meet this
guy Jeff go a weird conversation for a
post hookup but cool I'll go with it and
so what you're like cool I'm so excited
I can't wait to reach other Jeff goal I
love that that's hustle movie so you
call me like I'm your bro yeah are you
Jeff this is Jeff Cole yeah basically
you like this is Brazil yeah basically
this is that's pretty accurate
yeah keep going and literally it was you
know we worked a company on company and
you know I was always in number two or
three at the company definitely under
incentivize underutilized I always had
Jeff as a designer and just the work
ethic second to none his designs I mean
usually them everyone knows it and it
came to a point where we were with these
companies we weren't really happy and
about it's now probably bout 16 17
months ago we went from Squarespace to
Shopify and through obviously we were
bartering on Instagram and getting big
post making a couple thousand dollars
here and there but the second we started
doing paid ads month one six figures and
then we just went on a bender Facebook
Facebook so Facebook and Instagram is
where the company started and iconic
iconic the correct tonic and you should
probably know how to pronounce this Jedi
investor
yeah I can't pronounce my own and it
literally was don't worry it was me Jeff
and then we were running ads and his 16
year old brother
paying 25 cents the process the orders
and we were part-time you paying 25
cents an order
no no but you bring him 25 cents in
order to prep yeah not get a fine Jeff
was because I was giving him some
sneakers so we did we did our first 2
million dollars on top on revenue from 5
a.m. to 8 a.m. and then at 5:00 or 6:00
p.m. when our partner the other company
left when that door shut that was the
best moment of our life we'd go and get
coffee and then we'd be jacked from 5:00
or 6:00 till 3:00 in the morning and
then I got to a point where we're like
wow this is getting serious and then
that day we went all in and then things
just took it to a whole new well since
we haven't framed it up what is the
company for everybody listening iconic
is affordable art starting at $50 to
$700 it's all directed consumer the core
of the company kind of has that
motivational inspirational DNA and that
kind of drove us to become a legitimate
company and now we've iterated and so
you know with the NBA license right you
do it you do licensing and original
right correct
manly original yeah it was Jeff that did
all the designs for the first about year
and now we're starting to bring on more
designs artists that [ __ ] with you cuz
you're a coal count is so fired on
Instagram that would DM you you'd vet
and you're like oh [ __ ] the second scale
he makes fun it's my surrogate biz dev
100%
d-roc is how we've you know like the
rock world is like whether it's babban
or caleb like we found way better people
indie rock by people that were hitting
up the rock I found so Wendy Rock posted
Austin our video guy yeah we found our
second Austin or second video got
through that so basically D Rock found
both do you rock is literally like a job
board like yo what's up would too you
know a lot of people call other video
people D rock like that has become like
a real right like you he's Rd rock yeah
like that has become a real thing which
is really [ __ ] amazing in a lot of
ways but when I hear D Rock I'm like oh
yeah that's like a job board like like
that's how I literally think about it
though you haven't been able to find
somebody from our team like I
miraculously everybody's finding lots of
stuff yet we can't find another person
for our team yeah I mean that's
yeah that's the problem we have like
duplicating Jeff you know oh so hard
you've tried getting junior design right
because when you know t2d rocks point
and I don't know if you guys heard it
here on the podcast so I'll repeat it
finding somebody that bleeds that bleeds
out of their eyes which is a term I use
for just like work ethic it's hard to
find somebody who is both artistic and
outrageously in a not only a work ethic
because there's a net ours right like an
artist could work 18 hours but if her or
his output is a single piece of content
where our requirement for 18 hours is
837 that's a big [ __ ] Delta like for
me in my lane I want bleed out of their
eyes and intelligence because I can
develop that with him it's skill talk to
me about when he became a better
businessman than you buy mainly just
listen to me Wow when did he become a
better businessman than you on the back
you know but most of those are directly
coming from me right yeah
okay just we got to a point our which
ones I'm a better businessman than you
oh I'm just we're just trying to play
the game right now the market says you
are as you as what you would say the
market says you are yeah that I'm young
how old are you I do I just turned 33 a
couple we can have a good thank you bro
thank you I know have you found that to
be you to your advantage so me girl stay
if I don't believe them to be honest
with you you think they're pandering to
you I think so but what about the huge
headlines of me and scooter being
involved has that helped your thinks
things have changed this this this
interview is going not where I wanted to
go my uh well here's why yeah cuz I
rarely do anything that I own platform
yeah so I figured before we get to the
calls I'm gonna make this interview
nothing like you dreamed it up right
yeah who thought like I'd set it up
knock it out
celsa [ __ ] our casa mainly I'm making
sure that you remember the pain of a me
makes me short of that we talked about
the gray you know like I'm going
completely different places with this is
that fair it's fun no on a serious note
what's what's you know here's the reason
I said yes yeah because you guys fully
[ __ ] executed on my core thesis that
I've been trying to shove down the
[ __ ] from wrote of society and you
guys know the same way I know
that were not that special so self-aware
it's all software it's just there's a
moment in time right now that people for
some reason and listen I'm pretty good
at [ __ ] like forcing my message down
people's throats there's this inherent
human thing that people are just not
willing to take advantage of this
ludicrous opportunity how its reduced
like you say Facebook Instagram
influencers and people aren't doing it
it blows our minds like we're pushing so
hard there and we're finding other
distribution channels now we can get you
know cheap traffic but give me one just
give it to me scared tabouleh it's a
random well I know what it is yeah
tabouleh so I'm happy with that we're
happy with Aaron hood like how we're at
right now how the business is structured
I look at his three things everything
starts with content you could do know
paid traffic if you have good content
you can blow up and then the other two
big things and let's stay here because
this is really why I wanted you guys cuz
I want to bring value to my audience
you're right you can blow up with no
paid no money but that will take some
time correct even the best of content
it's not like you're if you're the fire
fire if you're the next mean you're
gonna Trump me your name's Sally you're
gonna [ __ ] destroy me if you just put
out your first video on Instagram right
now it's gonna take a few minutes it's
gonna take a [ __ ] few minutes if
you're authentic though you're gonna
find some people some percentage one two
three and just after like you said you
tomorrow I'm gonna wake up early as [ __ ]
and I'm gonna go garage saling and I'm
gonna make fire content cuz it's a dude
on a serious note it really meant a lot
to me that you did first it was crazy
the other day like I really kind of did
it first of all it was the most creative
I like right like I'm looking at my team
like I'm more creative when I do garage
sale content like I'm doing a picture
than a video and little Tamar I'm gonna
[ __ ] destroy doors me the great story
of all time I'm gonna find something
crazy that NASA jack it was nuts
one for 82 one for $1 bought it for a
[ __ ] dollar 82x
uh anyway yeah so so content and then I
think the two big things is you know you
call it attention we call it traffic yes
anything yes so you know now as you know
leading the company I'm a busy guy yes I
just want as much traffic as possible
awareness then the last thing which
people I really
don't think focus on is conversion tak
100 per second vert that how do you get
one uptick and there are two extremes
you guys are who sales misses your
retail where I come from right you're
selling art I sold wine so you're
absolutely right about conversion I and
this I want to give everybody the full
look I'm actually so deep right now into
brand yeah that the reason I go so deep
into non conversion mmm-hmm is cuz I
want to be on the other side of just
like pure brand right like if Nike tried
to get you to actually buy their product
in everything they do well they wouldn't
be brand well I do think that we've
shifted a lot towards a lot more Brown
don't know if you've seen our account
but since we've spoke yeah it took a big
big shift I'm aware where it's just
story telling straight I'm watching a
look obviously we had that combo
obviously I'm happy to watch you do it
I have seen it obviously the headlines
of me and scooter investing in the
company were a big was a big deal and
just brought general awareness and
there's so much more to go yeah and I
think when you get those two things
singing mmm-hmm it gets real scary yeah
like when we think about all the stuff
we're selling with the sneakers and
different stuff like I got a big wine
project coming up like when you get when
you get brand and selling down like if
Nike had 5,000 people in a call center
cold calling doing tactical stuff you
they would do better yeah like I don't
think people like you know like now when
you start at trillions and billions it's
hard to get your juices going but for
like oh 99.9% of the people watching it
by the way is a Facebook Facebook if
you're watching right now putting your
phone numbers I really want to go into
call and show I want to establish with
these dudes were but I realize you can
tell I wanted a razzle it on have fun
just that a family love give you a
little context that the only reason here
I listen I do a lot of investing a lot
of stuff why are these dudes here they
[ __ ] listened like I don't was it
Justin G grande traveler who yeah yeah
so a guy that works with me great guy at
Vayner sports one of AJ's right hands
connected us I went in like courtesy
yeah like I'm always meeting new people
it wasn't courtesy I'm always fishing
but I'm not like interested in fish
right now I don't think you know that we
I guess you don't know the whole
backstory probably not
maybe I do we say we garrard garrard
because what happens is believe you
talked about it asked to do his logo he
did it we charge a lot and I go one more
time
I didn't Boehner Sports rebrand you did
yeah yeah don't know that and well it's
amazing I feel way better a bit and
there you go no I like it they go how
much and I go Jeff we're not gonna
charge them we're gonna provide value
first and when she Grande this is gia
grounded done and she got a slick and
then six months later I emailed you
Grande I go where Guerra disciples
here's the last six months of revenue
give us 50 minutes with Gary and then he
screenshotted a text message he had with
you and then we got that 15 minutes at
Beverly Hills and all I need is the in
person I knew when we met in person get
it game over explosive and it was and
then it was so real that's the other
thing with us that I I think especially
living in LA is no matter where this
company goes or where we go me and Jeff
are value first with everything like
right now there's one person that I
think I owe something to obviously
besides my family someone that I they
gifted me something I haven't posted it
on Instagram everything else I'm putting
out there I'm doing for other people and
I think that's the other thing that
people you know you're talking about
brand over sales
I think it's value first couldn't agree
more that so many peopre Sh it's it's
leverage it's you have the leverage you
made a [ __ ] comedian [ __ ] logo that
led to like all this very true you know
what I mean though like I'm obviously
like downplaying well you made a logo
and like whatever money was there no
matter how much you charged it was
disproportionately less you know like
then the value gotten returned by
yourself light and to your point like
I've gotten to you know you youngsters
are gonna love this you're gonna get to
a point where you're giving without
actually worrying about if you're gonna
get to me like when it gets real fun
we're starting again I believe it where
we don't leave you I don't excuse doing
it yeah it's not like okay one day
Kobe's gonna [ __ ] sit with me or I'm
gonna get to and by the way that's the
right way to think about it because if
you're really good at listen I probably
subconsciously still do things with the
thought of like oh [ __ ] but I'm gonna
[ __ ] you know that's gonna help me win
a buy the Jets but where I got probably
a decade ago but more likely maybe even
half a decade ago zero expectations like
if gia Grande said go [ __ ] yourself you
would be blown away by how now in my
life and it still happens no matter who
you are there's always other things
right yeah it doesn't
register now I'm not gonna overly go
crazy for a geografía I'm going that's
where she giving without expectation is
the ultimate I agree you got questions
cool let's go let's get some Collins I
think some people can no introductions
dude I'm about to like go deep into the
scene I'm getting excited this is epic
yeah
so while Andy's pulling up the call
because I'm curious cuz I was so
impressed with how much PR like that you
could feel the buzz
you're gonna lot already our PR agent
barters my favorite record I want a barn
in my whole life who's this hello Rafael
its Gary B you're on the show hey Gary
what's going on that things are good my
guy what do you have questions with
walking you guys and uh yeah I've been
grinding for a little while man I have a
physical therapy company trying to take
it at trying to scale and it's just been
really hard and like kind of grind and
trying to find Robin to my Batman so to
speak when you're looking for Robin what
are you offering Robin like yo help me
build my [ __ ] or are you giving up some
of the equity I'm always offering equity
and just from the gate you know what a
lot of times I don't know what it is but
you know I'm not sure if as people don't
believe in themselves they don't believe
in the vision it's really kind of hard
to find somebody who's like okay yeah
like let let's do it like from the door
from the gate I got it don't look so
tell me now tell me tell me this I get
it I get it
tell me this how many um what are you
looking for Robin to do honestly what
I'm looking for Robin to do is kind of
bring to the table some things that I
don't have you know I do not always I'm
not the most charismatic person before
like a Robin who can help me with trying
to tell me I'm not the most charismatic
person I'm like damn really that's not
where I thought you were going cuz I
like the way you're talking keep going
yeah like you know I'm not the most
charismatic guy
I can see how you know someone can move
to a room kind of help with connect like
I can close a deal you know I'm at a
table I can negotiate I can you know you
know I know my numbers I'm on top of all
this kind of stuff you know that's kind
of my strength not really you know the
the intro you know it's not charismatic
it's the first move once there once
they're farming the hunting is harder
for you once it's farming you've got it
there you go
okay keep going so that where do you
live where do you live
holidays I live in a suburb Haditha live
in AI and Maryland okay DC Maryland got
it looking for Robin yeah who's she or
he is good at hunting keep going and
what do you want to sell them physical
therapy not just physical therapy but
got some ideas and since we're you know
you you got a Wow Reese I want to put
all my ideas out there but I'm trying to
kind of innovate as far as how the
services are delivered of course you
know health care you know it's changing
it's trying to get really squishy as far
as you know the margins going down but
the pay is still high so I'm trying to
find a way to change the game as far as
how it's delivered the method is deliver
and so and so forth
you could say anything yeah I mean it
looks like you're looking for a
glorified sales person and I think for
that you know just going on job boards
you can probably find someone and I
think the fact that you're willing to
offer equity to go with obviously some
sort of salary is something that not
many people are willing to offer at the
gate so I think you have a pretty good
offering have you tried just utilizing
resources and looking for a salesperson
oh I have a lot of my lot of my friends
are salespeople but the thing is is that
I have further to tell people I have
other associates that are salespeople
but one thing I've known what I notice
about salespeople they're not always
entrepreneurial they're really good at
sales but then really risk-averse and
when you have people who are risk averse
it's like they're they're out of the
game before you even you know you know
before you even get the door I mean
I'm dealing with a fire right now scuzz
I felt like you had it down but like to
me very simply like you like I mean I
feel like he needs to be going on
networking events and and just be out
there more like for us and we're just
out there and it's a contact sport
that's how I see it that's how I see it
yeah I also think like honestly man like
like I caught the tail end of like the
risk-adverse this and that like I just
would spend no energy on you know what's
wrong or what's not or what's tough I'm
just fascinated like it's it's
fascinating to me that catching the tail
end I apologize that I have to just take
care of this it's fascinating to me that
I never once in my life
blamed the customer and I don't know
like I'm not saying I'm right and you
[ __ ] up like I don't even want to go
that I'm trying to bring value for
everybody listening holy [ __ ]
never in my life we were reading
something today they were working on
this cool [ __ ] project and in it the
customer wasn't blamed yeah I did pick
it at it but you guys had it there's
this Authority that I was listening to
by the team it's I don't want to go too
much into it
but the bottom line is net-net I was
proud of the team I didn't touch it at
all in this story let's just stick with
that the customer was not blamed and I
took note of that that was like good
they did a good job I recommend for you
of like forget about risk-adverse that
how many people have you asked if 17
people were risk adverse when you
approached him or 1700 or 17,000 that's
still nobody in the scheme of the game I
feel like that's answer that's poor
people that's it yeah that's it okay and
explain any that sound smart you always
going offense it's on you yes right yeah
man listen finding Robin or selling to
clients this new delivery mechanism that
you have it's all about just finding
people that say yes in the beginning
everything I've ever done in the
commerson 96
social media you know agency and
ix these were [ __ ] things that nobody
wanted all I got were nose I found a
couple of [ __ ] yeses and everybody's
out here trying to [ __ ] think that
everything should be a yes does that
make sense right
so like I think just making that mindset
all of a sudden the way it manifests is
you're not dwelling on that no you're
not worried that you kissed another
Joker instead of finding a Robin you
understand yeah my daddy today cool man
well good luck all right good luck man
thank you and say like right sometimes
you know it's like I'm always fascinated
I'd like the macro versus the micro
advice like usually young that's gonna
be sure I like that I can go micro we
had to go macro on him that's why I was
like there wasn't really an answer I
think it's just it sounds crazy so
mindset it's just work harder kind of
it's just keep at it keep going working
harder you know it's funny and I believe
in working harder but it's work harder
with the right perspective yeah like
it's a lot easier to work 17 hours a day
when you know why you're doing it I was
so pissed that's such an OD video I
literally googled like like I just think
like people are like but the markets not
ready for my I remember what John Legend
when the guy was like yo people aren't
ready for my [ __ ] like [ __ ] you
so sucks stop blaming listeners yeah
like like when you're like when you have
an art piece that doesn't sell as well
like I still love when I would send an
email write the copy pick a wine buy a
wine try to sell the wine and it didn't
sell it be like yeah I suck
instead of like all these people don't
know that Pinot Grigios the [ __ ] are
hoses
Andrew Andrew you're on the show you can
please call the office at 231 unanswered
basic let's try them again or somebody
else you remote to say something I think
the whole entire thesis is just with
every no you're getting closer and
learning and refining like our whole
entire thing is we love the micro losses
because it's just it's getting us closer
100% just getting better and better and
better that's the whole entire the micro
loss for the macro like
whole life some micro loss just to buy
the Jets and win six Super Bowls that's
it
first I'm gonna my first game ever cut
though they're very good team
[Music]
then some words a player do David don't
[ __ ] up just shut up David your call has
been forwarded to an automated
voice-messaging system nine one nine
eight zero one two three six zero is not
available at the tone please record your
message when you've finished recording
you may hang up or press one for more
options
David it's Gary Vee listen life is so
[ __ ] interesting the fact that I will
never call you back in the history of
our life fascinates me that this moment
in time like who knows why maybe you're
in a bad service area maybe you want to
go take a quick [ __ ] I don't know why
you didn't pick this up but the fact
that you didn't which led to this
message that will now create a scenario
that will never interact ever again
blows my face off of like how life
actually works how long ago did he have
a good all right do you rock what's this
this is the camera that we were using
you and I and we're gonna sell this on
eBay you're gonna sell this on eBay Seth
and you are gonna sell us an eBay and
the plan is we're taking this three
thousand four thousand dollar camera you
and I are gonna sign it and they're
gonna put it on eBay and see what
happens you're gonna tweet it out I'm
gonna retweet it I'm excited about this
I can sign it anywhere I'm so into this
t rocker I'm so pumped by you this is so
cool like we got our D Rock it's a job
board alright what is this
yosef yes
yosef maybe Joseph okay it's a y-yeah
hello Yosef it's Gary Vee and you're on
the askgaryvee show
[Music]
hello how are you we're tremendous you
watchin the show
no I closed it how was it though before
you left and Brokaw awesome but it's the
customer's always right so it must have
sucked no no no no he's doing a couple
of homeworks
that's why hold longer grad yeah women
you pay go home work on a Friday night
over the askgaryvee show live on [ __ ]
Facebook yeah because I can watch it
later on that's why he won huh
Joseph you're off to a good start
brother what's your question for the
guys where I I'm sorry do you have a
question you put your phone number in oh
yeah I was wondering how you do you keep
to yourself motivated and like you keep
going like I keep watching your videos
and like after it like an hour I just
got like there's no there's no like no
more you know you just it goes away
okay so you watch a video you get pumped
as [ __ ] for an hour but then it goes
away is what you're saying
yeah okay I'll let you guys answer first
on how you guys personally motivate
yourselves personally I think motivation
is all tied to finding something in life
that you're passionate about yep and
it's tied to effort okay oh like for us
we just work 24/7 we love what we're
doing and it's gotten to a point now
motivated by actually loving the process
the process is amazing we don't want
this to end
ever ever it's weird people ask us now
you know would you sell the company we
don't even know that answer anymore
right we just love it every single day
is amazing so passion hold on something
you're passionate about
and you can put the effort in Cole yeah
I just have an insane ambition like I
want to be the best in the world so it's
hard and it's like even like the
announcement with you like everyone's
like wow was that like the best year
like no it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like you
celebrated maybe for five minutes we did
a high-five and we went right back to
work it's you don't know it's the
ambition for you it's ambition it's are
you some love of the process love you
it's obviously there's a lot of things
everyone you have ambition you love the
process but your answer is ambition I
want to be all time the greatest you
for me what's interesting is I'm gonna
go a different angle because I'm this is
gonna help a lot of people that watched
my [ __ ] I'm super humbled as you can
imagine that right that I can be an
energy boost you know watching a video
mine much better move than doing some
[ __ ] coke or drinking some [ __ ]
redbull right like I'm excited by that
right by the reason that people aren't
sustained you know by my content in the
scenario that you preached is because
you're using it as a band-aid instead of
fixing the issue at hand now couple
things I'd like to ask you this because
of the way you set up this conversation
you might not be motivated as [ __ ] right
now
and maintaining it because you're
actually in a phase of your life when
you're eating some crow to set up the
next thing something have you found your
passion yet cuz I think once you find
your passion it's hard for their
motivation to kind of die oh I know I
want to do something that helps people
but I'm trying to like find either like
a pre l-like a health field bum not sure
yet yes I want decided like I'm I'm
studying good go ahead
no no please go ahead I'm like I'm not
I'm a sophomore right now in Rutgers and
I'm not sure what nature all I know I'm
like I want to go into the health field
but I'm not sure which specific cuz I
want to give back to the people like I'm
American Egyptian I want to go back to
Egypt and help out over there because
the health care system is just sucks so
their planet so so a couple things I
think I'm glad you asked that question
jump because I think that led into like
my entire thesis my intuition is look if
you want to be in the health field today
in 2019 unlike being an entrepreneur you
do have to go to college like like you
know like and maybe maybe I'm under
educated on the whole field and so I
don't know but like intuitively like if
you want to go to a top doctor you know
hospital it's hard for me to think like
you're coming off this like eighteen
year old me me like yeah oh [ __ ] college
I'm not going to med school like you'll
hire me dog I'm pure talent yeah like I
don't know if that's playing out like I
don't know if that's a 20-19 playing out
maybe 2027 maybe some entrepreneurs or
some rogue [ __ ] start a hospital
that's like all about like just
evaluating on some intuition [ __ ] I
don't know but right now it I feel like
it actually your question and where I
was going
yosef maybe what you're doing right now
is you can't get macro motivated cuz
you're in the eating [ __ ] phase you're
gonna check the box at Rutgers to find
the thing then go to premed
like you might know that you're in
[ __ ] year 1 & 2 of a eight-year
[ __ ] window of eating [ __ ] before you
get to actually do the thing you want
does that make sense yeah like I was
unmotivated as [ __ ] in high school like
they're like outrageously unmotivated
all I was doing was going through that
process to get me to the time and where
I found my motivation was on my side
hustle and that's why I got D's and F's
cuz I literally was trying to sell
baseball cards and study wine in every
minute of my life that I could get away
with it if I had a passive teacher who
didn't give a [ __ ] like I was a hundred
percent studying baseball cards and wine
every class and I don't mean like haha
and Gary was I mean open the [ __ ] it
Beckett baseball card guide or the Wine
Spectator sit in class and read it
hoping my teacher wouldn't say something
so I think you might just be in the
eating crow era
would that make sense yeah look don't ya
me like does that make sense or like
damn it then yeah what are you yeah are
you okay with that that becomes the
thing like I was okay with giving up
you're the reason why a [ __ ] on
everybody and come so hard is I was okay
with giving up my 20s and mid 30s to
give back to my parents I was okay with
that and everybody else like so many
outs are just like trying to do all the
funnest stuff and like have everything
like I was okay with paying fifteen
years of do samman I look at did you
know how much respect I have for you on
this man you were okay with commuting
from [ __ ] New York shitty New York I
assume to [ __ ] Jersey to work at Wine
Library for ten or eleven eight five
dollars an hour whatever [ __ ] it was
because you were like [ __ ] I'm gonna
eat [ __ ] for a year and hope Gary's not
full of [ __ ] and puts me on you were
okay with that and clean enough I know
how it is at Wine Library did it too so
like I know what dad's up to they're
like you know like
like intercept so I think the question
you have to ask yourself if you're so
ideological that you're gonna go back to
[ __ ] Egypt and save the [ __ ]
health care system of Egypt well then
guess what eating [ __ ] in University in
America for seven years in your 20s is
minor leagues to the ambition coming out
of your [ __ ] mouth my guy god yeah
take and take every single class and
every single class in the medical pocket
and when you find that one thing you
like then you're gonna penetrate that
one rocket or take every [ __ ] class
that has nothing to do with medical and
realize junior year in [ __ ] Rutgers
that your [ __ ] poet that to knows for
sure I'm not but but but you see where
I'm going with this yeah like I think
the important part like the money shot
of this was like is the ambition coming
out of your mouth something that you're
willing to pay the dues for I am so bent
out of shape tired of [ __ ] hyperbole
spitting out of people's mouths of what
they're gonna do and then when they have
to go and put in the thing to get them
there they [ __ ] block because I'll
tell you this Yousef this is about the
rewiring of perspective you might float
into happiness and motivation for the
rest of your life if you understand on
this Friday night that the game is
having the tolerance to eat the [ __ ] to
get you in position to do the thing
Thanks all right what do you think talk
with me here talk with me I'm into this
I put it no I totally agree with you so
then so how is it processing is it
processing like oh [ __ ] that might be
right [ __ ] it I'm gonna like go all-in
and I'm gonna find pockets of like
playing 2k or going on dates or like
I'll just I'll appease myself in the two
hours I get to myself outside of this
crazy education thing that I have to
check the box on for the next six years
cuz I'm gonna go [ __ ] save the
Egyptian [ __ ] medical world or are
you saying like oh [ __ ] do I want to
change the Egyptian medical world or
both most kind of yeah
cool man I mean I think that's super
right that's exactly what your [ __ ]
20s is supposed to be yeah you don't
have to [ __ ] figure it out but I
think what you need to think about is a
lot of 20 year olds get real ideological
and like one thing you may want to think
about is is it even capable of fixing
the Egyptian medical world because I'll
tell you what really is scary to me when
I hear you talk I've had drinks with the
46 year old version of you Yousef and
you know the 46 year old version of you
have said to me oh [ __ ] I wish that I
knew that there was no chance of
changing the Egyptian medical world so
one thing I would tell you to do very
carefully is while you're going through
this process audit the reality of your
playing field to see if what you're
actually saying is even [ __ ] possible
that's a big problem there's smaller
problems within that problem that's why
I would correct it find a pocket where
you can solve something small that can
contribute I think that's right
solving the bigger I think that's right
I think you know when you're 20 you're
gonna rule the world right as you should
I love it I want everybody to but where
I'm going with is a level of
practicality that doesn't trap you that
you wait what people do when they're
ideological is they're faced with
something at 31 we're like oh [ __ ] all
of this is [ __ ] facts again yeah you
see where we're going you said yeah here
and the reason this is all easy for me
to give you is it's based on the one
hour boost of motivation the reason it
fades is because it's a band-aid it's a
quick high off my communication style
that is wonderful I'm very proud of it
but it's because we haven't gotten to
the root of the thing that you're not
able to keep consist aend
motivation you know what I mean all
right and cuz it's either you're lying
to yourself of like what's coming out of
your mouth isn't true in your heart and
your brain or something else and I
really think it's usually like when I
hear what you had to say it's that
there's a part of you the logical part
of your brain that's quiet and a voice
that whispers to once in a while that
says
that's actually not that possible or to
Sabaton which is why I think you know
Brazil's talking about it the right way
which is like instead of boiling the
ocean why don't you say like I'm gonna
[ __ ] change the life of a hundred
Egyptians in the town that my
grandparents came from now you're like
[ __ ] I can actually do that not trying
to curb your dreams either it's just
something you start there and then you
can build upon that a hundred percent or
look look I said I was gonna buy the New
York Jets big [ __ ] dream it's just
that I knew there was gonna be a bunch
of dog [ __ ] for a [ __ ] a half a
century to get there mm-hmm like
yesterday you know all the tweets come
out when I get salty about a Jets win
don't worry Gary are you gonna buy the
Jets in five years I like the Amika I'm
like no I'm not close 20 you know so I
think you got to be real with yourself
Yousef wouldn't you synthesize the last
[ __ ] in 15 minutes just realize go with
myself and just try find the real thing
that's exactly right and the way to do
that the way to do that bro is to taste
I think you and I gave the right advice
taste taste right every taste all right
like for the people that found it good
now quadrupled down for everybody else
who's listening to this and be like [ __ ]
that's me go fencing start a pottery
class go with like say hello to nine
people that you've seen on campus 48
times but you don't know their name
Yussef I suck at 80% of things in life
just so you know you said I suck at 99%
of things in life I'm being dead serious
my guy you said you're definitely doing
this for you right like you don't feel
like this was instilled by like mom or
aunt or sister not some documentary cool
good good man now I just got listen if
the rules of your game or the game that
you're playing you've got to follow them
you can't get out of education to get in
a position to do what you want in the
current world so eat it the same way
that I want it to be in the liquor
business to help my dad's business and
all the liquor laws did it
these [ __ ] can show when they talk do
you understand how angry I get that they
can ship art anywhere and I couldn't
ship wine to Pennsylvania and Boston and
all these places people don't know what
I thought I hated it but guess what I
chose to [ __ ] get into my dad's
liquor business so I don't get to cry
that I couldn't ship wine to all
places that's the business I'm in you
don't get to cry that you have to do
school for next seven years and you
[ __ ] hate it
you want to save [ __ ] Egypt you just
want to go save Egypt
Yousef are you ghost yeah you said you
were like letting that settle in yeah
and what do you what did he came out of
you settling that [ __ ] statement what
came out on the other side of your
thoughts I just have to you think and
like realize it's my it's my real
dreamer it's just I feel like my while
like my twenties thing yeah let me give
you let me give you a good one bro let's
like get to the real point this is
probably ultimately now I'm starting to
realize why the [ __ ] I kept you on the
phone or is it a dream that you
subconsciously liked the way it
positioned you amongst others no every
time if I think you like that Dad I just
like shove it down because I don't want
like no Fame I just wanted to if just
for the people not not the fame brother
not the fame the way that your mom dad
sister person you like six homies you're
inert eleven [ __ ] fame do you think that
maybe this is your ambition because you
like the admiration of the inner eleven
when they look at you when you say
you're gonna do this no I don't think so
good that's great because this big
problem that's in the game huge problem
for a lot of people and I'm pumped
that's great this is what you see how
thoughtful these questions are like like
I'm listening to you like I believe you
like honestly I thought there was a good
chance that that was the answer I'm not
kidding but when you answer I'm like who
will actually feel that that's good so
like these are the this is the process
this is the process that everybody needs
to do thoughtful questions real life
questions you understand yeah I'm
Shannon
help me one more time because I think
you're gonna help a lot of kids out
there bro what one more time I know you
said it but like where are you at right
now
I know milkiness but I'm loving it
because I think it really will help what
I can't refuse a question a hundred
percent
what's on your [ __ ] mind right now I
just want to get my grades straight just
focus on that getting to the best school
misconnections try like do my point in
my dream love it let me tell you a
couple things you're gonna love don't
over I'm a bigger believer in
serendipity then I am on the brand
positioning of these schools let me
explain don't burn yourself out trying
to get certain grades that may not come
natural to you because these are the
four best medical schools and you're
gonna go to number 17 because let me
promise you one thing the way you said
it you can find the person that's gonna
cure cancer at school number 17 just as
easily as you can at school number one
so when I heard you say Network a lot of
times people think you got to go to
school number one and two but the way
the world's transforming and the way
that schools value certain data versus
the data that actually is gonna play out
over the next 30 years my recommendation
to you is do not to do the bare minimum
but I would be far closer to the bare
minimum then I would to strive to
something that's unachievable from a GPA
because you're gonna [ __ ] burn your
life out trying to get a three point one
and instead of a two point nine and at
the end of the day school number 11 in
Connecticut is not going to be the Delta
you think to school 21 in Virginia do
you understand yeah serendipity will
trump that every day 2.1 GPA great
network
yeah 1.7 man [ __ ] Network but I could do
it myself all right thanks man I'm sorry
one more question like I wanted to you
in person
what's your next event in New Jersey
yeah I know like what's gonna happen in
October for your wine club under 21 you
some how old are you I'm 20 I'm 21 in
December what's that I'm gonna be 21 in
December I'll probably do something I
but I probably I I have a high
likelihood of doing something in the
first weekend in December or second
weekend in December at Wine Library I
would argue that there's a bigger than
50% chance that I'll do a public event
on the first Saturday or actually I
could see Black Friday blocks I could
see a Black Friday Saturday Thanksgiving
thing did people tremble probably first
now I probably do first week of December
because if I do that Thanksgiving
weekend people can't travel and for me
to do a jersey event people travel from
Rhode Island Delaware PA so I would
argue first or second week in December
at Wine Library and that's will be the
next thing all right awesome
he was very real yeah let's sneak one
more in before we let these [ __ ]
good-looking dudes out yes you start a
DNF Club yeah that's a yeah dude I was
gonna be a reporter like I do mine was
five years 2.1 I needed to get a certain
grade class they got the two hun
nightmares that I didn't graduate high
school hello four years Scott it's Gary
view on the askgaryvee show
what's up man life is good what do you
have a question for me in the boys oh
yeah
so I mean I've known Jeff since Jeff was
like five we were up in the same
neighborhood okay be further when's the
last time you and Jeff have interacted
via technology or two days ago
okay okay well you guys are actually
what's your question Scotty yes he calls
getting pissed oh no Mike Mike Lenny for
before you go to question tell us a
great under-the-radar coal story oh yeah
like real under-the-radar one that you
don't eat not eat you know how you and
your homies have like the 38 stories you
keep recycling I want to hear a story
number 39 something that whole hasn't
even thought about in like 11 years give
me some like fourth grade like [ __ ] his
pants during recess [ __ ] oh you gentle I
mean um so I mean I don't I don't think
many people know that that Jeff is has
not always been the the hardest worker
in the neighborhood so Jeff and I
like Jeff was Oh a little bit of a
bubble maker made a little bit when he
was younger yeah so I I mean like test
like like roman candles are like no no
no I think I mean what about like
mission like like bats to [ __ ]
mailbox of [ __ ] no Jeff Jeff wasn't Jeff
wasn't that bad but like water balloons
at houses and and we had like I'll call
it the year older kids were like a gang
in the neighborhood okay and and Jeff
and I think Jeff would when he was a
little bit young I don't know if he
remembers but like I mean a couple kids
got in trouble because I my grandma was
staying over and she calls the cops on
kids throwing water balloons at our
house and all the kids have to line up
in front of our house and say sorry are
you sure those me Scotty I hope not I
don't think so I think I think I do
then then then I'm the one to see Gary
you're you're like I know what your
question question Scotty so my question
is is that is that Jeff and Mark
strategically brought Gary and scooter
in on this business yes and and there I
mean and you guys are obviously huge and
impactful people in in larger industries
yep our youtube gonna help build iconic
into the world's greatest and largest
art brand ever oh I'm not the answer is
nothing zero this is it askgaryvee
episode I mean never see these two [ __ ]
faces again I can't speak for scooter
he'll probably do incredible things like
he'll do a lot I nothing my preferences
I never see these two dudes again that's
my game plan what do you think Scotty I
mean I mean I know good and I've met
mark one time but we've interacted in
multiple times and I know Jeff forever
and uh I think I think it's possible I
think
is how I'm motivated I don't know man I
can I mean I don't know if Jeff's ever
told you the story of when we got to
meet up and link up in LA but but it was
a good time I mean just art perspective
what they're doing
combined Scottie whatever dude I want to
be your friend can I'm gonna fly you in
and you get the Scottie I'm buying you a
plane ticket you're coming to hang out
at Vayner for today I just I just need
you around telling stories I have more
stories than you can count
follow up literally right now Gary at
vaynermedia comm email and be like
Scotty from Chicago it's me and I you
know I want it I'm ready to come and you
email me right now I'm sure a bunch of
people about to email me just so
everybody knows no this is very simple
everybody who emails me that's not the
actual Scotty I will delete you from our
database forever and our servers and I
will probably also save it and publicly
shame you and make sure that you go deep
into the black web your social security
number will be mine within 24 hours
that's a real threat it is just want
everyone to know out there that they
better not impersonate me because I'm
taking like just like you said I mean
your whole thing is about taking
opportunity isn't it and Jeff and Mark
like that you take the opportunities you
follow up duty I cannot wait I'm gonna
walk through you can tell a story but
like yo this one time Jeff and I can't
wait I'm looking forward to Scott I'll
see you soon okay all right bye hey Andy
we need a real question [ __ ] Scottie
Jeff's best friend from fourth grade who
like so blow pops with each other
Scottie finesse them there that's nice
you sound like a good dude musica guy
good guy good vibes but we need to like
come in we need to end strong not
Scottie the [ __ ] storyteller the
stories I want to put his face on that
t-shirts well show him after hello this
is Jacob Jacob it's Gary Vee you're on
the askgaryvee show
no yeah
[ __ ] true oh my god and that language
comes for you Wow I'm here next time why
for watching you guys and I'm like I'm
like they're not gonna call me stupid
that's crazy well I'm actually talking
to Gary Vee I didn't give a [ __ ] anyway
what's the question my guy so so I have
a personal question and then I have like
a simple question not really simple but
my my my micro question is how would you
scale from like because I noticed
there's a process from going from six
figures to seven figures I haven't even
read six figures first of all my figures
tell the truth don't liar I'll hang up
take it easy now listen I don't know
maybe not maybe I've been starting at
having that right so what about what
about four figures tell the truth it's
okay yes okay all right so we're at four
figures the questions about six to seven
figures yeah
Andy's smiling sometimes I want to
destroy you because I want to focus on
four to five but I'm gonna let that
slide because I love you
keep going I'd say and I guess my
question
I do social media marketing I mean I'd
you obviously nothing compared to what
you do but I noticed that it's like a
system you have to have to get what you
want to get okay so it's just creating
that system is the process it seems like
like remarkably individual right like
for example my system is lots of humans
I like scaling through lots of humans
most people hate that because it's not
very profitable in comparison I like
having the gang around I like it I like
mentoring people that later go out into
the world or like to me staying with me
for 40 years or going out to the world
both winning formulas so that's a mod
that's my formula a lot of people make
eleven billion dollars a year sitting
behind a computer don't want to talk to
one [ __ ] person this is about
self-awareness at scale there is no
system don't buy a system figure
yourself out and create the system
around you uh you see what I mean there
and it's very impaired like everyone's
looking for the [ __ ] anecdote like
people are like oh yeah like yo what's
the secret hashtag
yeah like people ask me that kind of
[ __ ]
like yo-yo sucks like like you've got
like the keys to like [ __ ] Facebook
like good yeah Gary I didn't know that
what's that her a savage you post a lot
I knew that yeah the copy looks like you
but I was just thinking about the amount
that you post I didn't think it was you
yeah the copy look something because the
grammar is like nobody wants to talk
about it like it's crazy
Mike one of my great weaknesses was my
utter and back I mean guys this is me 20
years of writing email copy you should
have seen the first wine I'm dying I
have to figure out if we can somehow
miraculously find it but I can't even
imagine what the [ __ ] these poor wine
customers in conservative nineteen
nineties in a wine when you're writing
the email I was writing them and I'm
telling you 20 years later I'm like
[ __ ] Albert Einstein of grammar
compared to who I was 20 years ago even
the time you've probably right I can
even feel myself now better than I was
when we started like it's really cool a
huge weakness of mine is probably why
most people people don't think I do on
my own social media cuz they can't
fathom it but it's true I think the only
thing that even gives me a leg to stand
on I think is the copier when I started
writing longer form Instagram copy that
probably was the best thing that ever
happened to me because people like maybe
there's a prayer that it's me that's
good advice to him I took care of this
what's that long-form hobby focus on the
caption big big huge huge intuitive to I
use it in one word captions you rock
tell the story and he's about to steal
your story tell the story about the long
kashin
copy
long copy okay must be nice two thousand
likes yeah
okay nonetheless go Andy do you know
what you do before I'm actually lip what
people are saying you notice that we're
worried what are we talking about oh six
to seven authenticity that anecdote
right brow see there is there is no
[ __ ] anecdote well you need to do is
figure out yourself don't look at me or
Cuban or these guys or [ __ ] you know
Sara Blakely who crazy Spanx or [ __ ]
Beth Comstock who was on the show the
other day who's a beast in court print
this is so individual now there's
tried-and-true things being efficient
being passionate there's tried-and-true
things but like like for example I've
been working out now for four years like
look as much as I want to have like a
huge chest it's just not genetically
they're like I have other things that
could work and so like you have to wrap
your head around that [ __ ] like like
you've got to figure yourself out and
like like you know what really scares
the [ __ ] out of me is I push this all
the time yet as my popularity grows more
and more people are trying to be like me
and I'm a [ __ ] off the reservation
unique [ __ ] character like Mike
weighs ridiculously not mapable if it's
not your way yeah right like well I
think I'm the worst person to try to be
like
[Laughter]
[Music]
but that's what I mean that's why I'm
like look and then great I'm super happy
you know it's fine like I don't take any
pride in it it's like I'm not a good map
like I think there's a lot of people
that are much better map than me who oh
by the way most of those people when I
think of them make a lot more money than
me because it's more like kind of like
like I'm doing all sorts of crazy things
like if you [ __ ] are watching and
listening right now actually came here
and watched it for a week you'd be like
you'd kind of throw up your hands and be
like I don't even know I'm good right
right set what what do you think you
think he's nuts yeah that's the first
thing you want to talk about something
way scarier than I do my own social
media I am programmed from 7 a.m. to 11
p.m. every minute our first meeting was
5:15 to 5:30 I was our first 15 15
minute I count me in I was the first one
that's every Caleb that was
disproportionately the thing that was
most ridiculous right yeah I freaked
when like some weird [ __ ] happens we're
like that's why I like being here we're
like if something happens I'm like
uncomfortable in the not doing for three
minutes out of 18 hours in a day is it
true you've only had you only saw two
movies like every year somebody like one
movie yeah in this like going to the
movie theater and watching a movie
happens only in December during holiday
break and I'll see one end or two movies
during that time
see I I need to watch movie no that's
great that's your process I need to
watch the Jets take a [ __ ] [ __ ] in
Cleveland like everybody's got their own
like you know like everybody's got their
own thing like like I like I I don't
judge people watching movies or Netflix
or things of that nature
I think escapism is remarkable I think
I've hit this crazy vortex where my
[ __ ] work is my hobby my process my
love that I'm just like right like I
[ __ ] like I got home at 3 o'clock in
the morning from Cleveland
I've been going hard all day
this is like I've got three four more
things after this tonight it's already
8:45 and I'm waking up tomorrow at 6
o'clock the garage saling day when I can
actually catch up with some rest
people don't understand that and then
people like yeah this is where I get
crazy so that's me people feel bad for
you but like then like my friends like
wake up at 10:13 on Saturday like yo I'm
so tired and I'm like I'm gonna break
you're like I just you know but that's
okay like what you know my ambition is
absurd and so like I have to sleep in my
bed bro there's no process there's your
process you need to figure out you and
if you're the kind of person that needs
11 hours of sleep because that's your
DNA then get your 11 hours of sleep and
dominate the other 13 if you're the kind
that needs an hour for breakfast lunch
and dinner and watch YouTube videos of
like [ __ ] people climbing trees and
like that's how you roll then enjoy your
three hours of watching people climb
trees during your food consumption hours
and do you like I hate that people try
to be like me I over-the-top natural
energy that makes no sense to me and
anybody else that knows anything about
me that's just me and cool it works for
me in some ways here's a way it doesn't
work when you're that up when you're
that much of a beast you're you're often
the emotional and financial [ __ ]
infrastructure for everything you touch
and see so like you know everything's
got pros and cons so like don't wish on
yourself just figure out who the [ __ ]
you are and do what what would be your
number one industry to scale for for
social media marketing like as far as
what who should who should we target all
of them right now all of them all of
them
dude selling wine some sneakers selling
art like whatever they're all big every
markets biggest [ __ ] what do you want to
sell are you into like you want to be a
barber one day and sell blades like
bleeds [ __ ] came out bleeds dominated
[ __ ] razor blade yeah like [ __ ]
razor blades over the last seven years
is what it was if it's a shave clubhouse
margin it could be scaled
that's exactly right dude everything
people buy everything [ __ ] bananas
I'll give you one bananas I want you to
become
a king of the Internet I'm dead [ __ ]
serious like be the banana guy I was
watching when I was watching the Jets
last night out and they're like oh Gary
we think that tricking generated dude I
was I wanted to honestly I wanted to
like what did you do you like that
celebrate I'm calling him brother what's
that you've wiped plating cleanliness
frustrate dude the whole thing sucks
[ __ ] football [ __ ] question of that
you guys get to ask it what's your
question question of the day I'd say for
us we want to understand why consumers
are loyal to a brand so I would say what
makes you loyal to a brain I would say
what is your favorite brand and my
that's a because that's what we're we
want to know thanks for being on guys
congratulations love being with you guys
nice ribbon is all you keep asking
questions we'll keep answering them
[Music]